okay so for the tyo W this way first
always this
way don't come
out this isn't enough either
down okay rotates
in so let's just look at that elbow part
first elbow part here H that
turn Okay so just pay attention to that
as I do the whole technique
you're just looking at the elbow part
elbow
part all right next
part elbow is in don't just open this up
and try to walk under
this because we're even here I'm at the
distal end of my
lever and I'm at the distal end of his
lever only he's on top top okay so he
gets to use his lat uh as well as his
deltoid and this lat and the other back
muscles is going to overpower my outer
or upper deltoid here don't hurt me just
push down and I can't do anything
okay so elbows in this goes this
way if you watch his grip youve brought
his grip you see
it's not on top
anymore plus you've dis uh placed his
balance his posture plus Energy's going
that way making it a little harder to
push down
okay so in
boom just exaggerate that now we already
came over the elbow this way
boom boom
all right last key point is you even if
you were doing that you don't ever want
your hand out
there okay because he's strong
enough he can still do it on me he's
much stronger than me okay so you're
timing you have to bring your body with
your
hand instead of staying here you do your
hand and then you walk through you're
never going to get there
your whole body moves with your hand so
then you have your frame underneath you
here here okay so if you guys
recognize that upper block you see we
use this all this spiral all the time oh
we use this all the time you're using it
here again okay so R I'm I move with
soon as my hand is up that upper block
is there my body is underneath
it okay put it
together uh you got to time your grip
with his intention so you have to end up
here you don't want to try I to tie so
for so kiten in your normal katata DOI
grip okay so that's the first thing to
pay attention to it comes in boom I
don't do it beforehand so it'll end up
on top I want to end up
sideways
okay then of course you have your Fades
so you can do it with a weight shift
depends how fast he's coming in you can
do it with a f with a movement
okay here and a fade okay then you have
a inward spiral
again don't start doing inward Parry
from some different art you're not doing
that you're trying to get rid of
utilizing that inner deltoid so you're
here and you only have your inward
spiral but what you're going to do is
your edb1 con is going to be in
communion with that where I will stop
the the inward
spiral and then open it and you're now
in the completion of uai okay what I'm
trying to avoid is the inner deltoid
here
now inner spiral time it
hold okay here we go whether you're
doing
II or Soo your hands your hand is always
in this shape keep your grip please than
you're always fingers down and your back
H me on the AIT TAA okay you're not in K
back here with your fingers down we do
it again pay attention to camera oh Pop
boom here okay other hand is marking
your
Center so you're doing Soo it's the same
fingers down on Soo you are now in Ono
okay fingers down okay here we go